Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Birr.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 22nd,
2016 what's going on?
How,
how's it going?
Happy Monday to air each and every one of you.
I was going to say to every one of you,
then I decided to throw in each.
So that's why the each sounded weird there.
Just to let you know.
Um,
it's another beautiful day out here in Los Angeles,
uh,
getting ready to go out to fox woods.
Um,
this,
uh,
this weekend,
right?
Yeah.
Friday I'll be in New York City and then a Saturday and Sunday I'm going to be
at Foxwoods and um,
it's going to be hopefully going to be a good time.
I'm going to do a bunch of stand up this week so I'm not rusty old freckles.
Can't be walking in there rusty.
And I'm definitely looking forward to getting back there,
although I heard it's fucking freezing.
Um,
but whatever,
you know,
I can visit winter.
I'm a big fucking southern California softy now.
It get there,
my teeth chatter and when it gets in the forties it's actually not true.
And that shit to where they go,
all your blood thins out,
you know,
you blood thins out,
then you go back.
You can't,
it'll the cold.
It's like,
no,
that's not what happens.
You,
you're,
you have access to information in a beautiful life that you could be living
still within the parameters of this great country.
You know,
all you people back this shovel in that wet snob,
just letting you need,
you don't have to do it.
You know,
I took my dog out this morning battle about who do you know what I had on,
I had on a wind break
just walking down the street.
I could sit on my back porch in the sun right now.
Okay.
And burn another couple of cancer causing freckles into the top of my head.
Will,
I had a little bit of corn flakes,
you know,
sitting out there like the Douche in the goal.
Great nut commercials.
Zoe's some guy,
right?
He come out.
It was like he was a man's man,
but a pretty boy.
You know,
like Tom Brady,
except he couldn't throw a football,
that guy.
Right.
And he'd come out with the,
the impossible,
impossibly white robe
brand new white robe.
They even fucking bleached it.
Right?
The widest shit ever.
And He,
you know,
he's got a little fucking bullet grape nuts.
Always had some fruit in there cause he had that kind of time.
This guy was so successful.
He had the time to cut up fruit and do is fucking great Nazi.
He'd go out on his back porch and just chill.
I remember as a,
as a little boy,
as a little orange headed fucking freckled pussy.
I remember watching that just going like that guys hit guys live in the life.
Look at him.
Look,
I got wiped out.
Robust.
It's got fruit in his fucking grape nuts.
Guy's crushing it.
Who is he?
Fuck it.
Come on.
I want to see the rest of his life.
Let me see as less.
And that was the genius of that commercial.
They never showed his bro.
I don't think they did.
Maybe she came out afterwards.
You know,
I don't think so.
But that's the genius of it.
Had left you wanting more and you started thinking about his life and you
started thinking,
you know what,
you know what if I start eating great months,
maybe I'll have an impossibly white robe and I'll come out and I'll actually
have pigment in my skin,
you know,
nice full head of hair and I'll walk out on my deck barefoot,
look,
I like,
I got all the money in the world,
I got all the answers,
confidence,
hell and I even have time to cut up fruit in my cereal.
I want that life.
You know?
Here it is,
years later to this day,
you know,
I'm still eating great myths.
Sure.
I never got the pigment.
Yay.
I lost the hair.
Okay.
I had some structural damage to my house,
you know,
but I have tried to cut up some fruit.
Okay.
Spot.
I'm sorry.
Anyways,
yes.
So your blood doesn't thin out.
It doesn't thin out.
You just know what it's like to experience in 85 degree day and fucking
February.
And then you'd go back.
You just like what the,
you know,
and it's like,
it's like you ever see a rich person to have to stand in line.
It's the combination of frustration and confusion.
It's more confusion than frustration.
It's more like,
wait,
I don't wait.
I got money.
Like who came here?
Who wants this?
Who do I give this to so I can go around this?
I don't want to be with these animals.
Okay,
these are the people that make my dreams come true.
They show up at my factory.
All right.
They put the fucking,
that nut and bolt and the widget
that I bought off of somebody else,
they came in with the design.
They didn't have any money.
I made him sign a piece of paper where I own the patent to their idea.
I go around all this,
right,
rich guy,
thoughts in the ditches and confusion.
It's like,
why am I,
I don't do this anymore.
That's what West Coast people who've lived on the east coast.
Then when they go back east,
you know when we paratroop into fucking winner,
that's,
that's what would take like,
I don't do this anymore.
These chap faced fucking animals back here.
I'm a fucking doing the shoveling wet snow,
stretching out your back,
you know,
all excited cause you got a new snowblower,
you know that's your winner.
That's for you.
I,
I go around that man.
I don't do that shit.
I'm out of my back porch.
No bathrobe beat some great months.
So I'm doing it to my fucking dog is laying on his bed right now.
Okay.
It's like from the neck down.
It's on the bed and then like it's head is hanging off of the bed onto the
hardwood floor.
I mean it looks literally like a got hit by a tranquilizer.
Yeah.
All right.
And you know what I did with what?
The dog today.
This is why she's so exhausted after at least 11 hours sleep last night.
The fucking thing goes to bed at like seven at night.
It's hilarious.
Like whenever I'm watching the game and I'm just sitting there,
she's like over in the corner,
just curled up in a ball,
sound asleep.
Okay.
Which is why now for,
so I can't get her off this clock here.
She keeps,
I don't know how to keep her up,
you know,
cause she keeps waking me up at like five 30 quarter to six in the morning.
It's driving me nuts.
So anyways,
so now after 11 hours of sleeping,
I,
all I did was I took it around the block.
That's it.
Easy.
She looks like she ran a marathon.
I don't fucking know.
I don't understand why they're so goddamn sleepy all the time.
I've never,
I mean I've had dogs my whole life.
I've never seen a dog sleep the way this fucking thing sleeps.
Then it gets up at five 30 in the morning like a God damned drill sergeant.
The only thing it's missing is,
you know,
remember in full metal jacket when the guy came walking in and he was beaten a
Billy club against the empty trashcan.
That's basically what she does to me every morning except it's way more
adorable.
I'll be like sound asleep and then I'll,
I'm woken up to a cold nose doing that.
That fucking
psycho way.
They sniff it does,
that shit is fucking her paintbrush.
Tunc then I'm like,
ah.
That's how I wake up every morning and I'm one of those people.
Once you wake me up,
it's fucking over.
All right.
Just just to let you know,
in case you ever sleeping next to me,
you know,
keep it quiet.
Um,
all right,
let's move on.
Um,
as I mentioned on the Thursday,
uh,
after afternoon podcast just before Friday,
um,
that I was going to the,
uh,
the warriors game.
Um,
I was going to the warriors a clipper game and I was taking the lovely Nia and
uh,
cause I wanted to go see Steph curry in his prime.
You know,
you got to see them when they're young for they get the first major injury ever
before they just get old and reminds you that you're going to die someday.
You know,
you don't need to see that.
But during that,
you know,
I saw Michael Jordan back when he had hair.
I see them early.
All right.
When he was still skinny and the Pistons were beating the shit out of him and he
was dropping 60 on the Celtics,
I saw him then.
He's probably,
I saw him when he was staying with probably,
I think it was right before the Jordan threes came up.
I was probably the second pair,
by the way,
for the record,
when the first air of Air Jordans came out,
I thought they were the ugliest fucking things I'd ever seen in the,
in the red and black a bulls colors.
I thought they were the ugliest fucking things I'd ever seen it by the way.
Celtics fans,
how much more likable is Pau Gasol now that he's not on the Lakers.
I don't know what it is.
My hatred of the Lakers really just maybe hate that guy way more than I needed
to.
Um,
anyways,
so we go down to the game and um,
um,
yeah,
I'm like ridiculous,
excited.
Like I'm seeing one of the great NBA teams of all time and I'm seeing arguably
the greatest shooter this early in his career.
You can actually make that argument.
This is,
this guy's the greatest shooter in NBA history.
And in my lifetime,
I've watched Andrew,
Tony,
Larry Legend,
Reggie Miller,
and I,
I even throw Coby Brian in that,
I never saw a guy have two people hanging on him up by the three point line and
just with his back to the fucking hope and he's still somehow gets it in,
you know,
God knows he's not looking for the open man trying to beat the double team.
Why would you do that?
Anyways,
so I go there,
I get on stub hub,
right?
I fucking paid through the nose.
You know what I mean?
Fuck it.
Paid through the nose.
I get a six row behind,
uh,
not behind the bench but almost behind the warriors bench,
but whatever the fucking table where all the announcers are and shit,
I'm like somewhere in there,
six rows back.
And one of the great things is when you go to an NBA game is like if you're six
rows deep,
you can like literally hear them calling for the ball.
You know,
if like if the coach is Steve Kerr,
if he fucking cursed at the ref,
like,
oh,
what the fuck?
And he gets teed up.
I know what he said.
All right.
That's what I paid for.
That's why I went on stub hub and I said,
fuck it.
Huh?
You want a wheel bar?
Barrel full of cash.
Here you go.
I'm not fucking sitting all the way.
The staple center is the fucking worse.
You got to sit down low or else it's like they got this,
this brownstone of a corporate boxes,
three deckers,
three,
three fucking levels of them all the way around.
It's like a moat between the fucking haves and the have nots.
And then all the real fans,
they're up by the fucking air condition ducts.
So it's like that's what's the option as either way the fuck up their pay
through the nose.
So I said fuck it.
I'm going to pay through the nose.
Right.
So,
and I'm going to get there.
I'm going to hear him talking.
I'm going to watch some,
one of the great shooters of all fucking time.
And I get there,
dude.
And I know during all of this,
I'm going to sound like a grumpy old man,
but what the fuck happened to,
to,
to go into an NBA game?
Do they?
They didn't.
There wasn't one moment of silence.
The entire fucking gave to even play music when the fucking games going on.
I didn't hear one sneaker squeak.
I heard a couple of yo call for the ball.
That was it.
I heard nothing cause the entire fucking time that game's going on.
Some fucking do.
She's playing everybody clap your hands.
Tick,
tick,
tick to the whole.
They played that fucking 50 fucking times.
First of all,
I walked into the fucking building,
right?
And I'm all excited.
Where's my seats?
I paid through the nose.
Here we go.
Right?
It's like when you go on vacation and use all your fucking miles was sitting up
in the front of the play.
You can't fucking wait to get on a plane.
Where's my big comfy fucking shake that I fucking paid for,
right?
That's the level of excitement I had.
And I go in there and I'm coming down to the seats.
And first of all,
there's some Dj guy,
there's always a fucking DJ.
You can't even buy a pair of fucking pants.
Now you walk into a store,
there's a fucking some sad look at Dj.
They're just shit now,
you know with his bad posture,
you know some hacky Jay just fucking play in music.
I love to with like curse words in it too.
Like you were in like a place of business,
you know,
because I'm fucking you to not right as
the plane like biggie and shit.
Right.
So,
um,
anyways,
this is fucking Dj.
Yeah.
And he's,
I don't know what the fuck he's doing every five seconds.
Make so no
people at section three.
I'd ready to do good every back.
So
game hasn't even started.
What the fuck are we it?
Huh?
Are you getting this hype for the game?
You fucking dope.
We're about ready to see the clippers and the warriors towards got five losses.
This is like watching the 96 bulls,
that tear that they're on.
I don't need you and your Richie Cunningham Varsity fucking clippers jacket out
there screaming and fucking yelling.
Oh,
it gets worse.
I might blow a fucking buy,
have an aneurysm on this one.
So I'm walking down going,
oh my God,
how long is this guy going to be yelling at us?
And meanwhile,
meanwhile,
by the way,
you know the clippers are out shooting around in the worries about ready to take
to court.
I'm going to get to watch Steph curry fucking hit like 18 three pointers in a
row,
you know,
that's what I want to see.
That's what I want to hear.
Okay.
I don't eat back.
So no,
I don't need that shit.
Right.
But you know,
it's a new day.
It's a new generation stair time.
I'm just a grumpy old man,
right?
So I get down on my sheet that I paid through the fucking nose for right on the
fucking aisle and the what looks to be,
it looks like Steph Curry's mouth guard that he's constantly fucking chewing on,
right?
And it's like this bracelet.
And I didn't know what it was.
It looked like a fucking,
it looked like a one of those things.
They stick in the Bonneville,
a men's urinal,
right?
Or urinal cake,
except he gets stick your fucking,
you could put it on your wrist.
So it's taped to the back of my seat.
So I immediately just flip the fuck a thing over the other side of my seat.
Okay.
Immediately I'm not participating.
All right.
Total contrarian,
Conti fucking standup loaner comic.
I'm not being part of the group immediately.
Right.
And I'll take that.
I'll take 40% of the blame of the rest of this fucking wine and shit.
All right,
but the other 60% I'm fucking right.
So I fucking flipped that thing over.
And the fucking Dj guy with the Richie Cunningham varsity clippers jacket is
down there and he's,
he's like,
everybody hold up you fucking urinal cakes and when you hold it up,
don't forget.
Dot
everybody clap your hands.
Tech Tech,
tech tech to do this is all going on,
right?
And Sanity call.
And by the way,
there's a bunch of fucking,
you know,
like I swear to God what said,
who's that fucking guy who does the,
he shows the nice comfortable tee shirts,
but for some reason he shoots like 12 year old girls in like sexual positions.
The fuck is the name of that company.
It's not amber congress and Fitch.
They were into like fucking,
what was it like a white supremacists,
Kennedy children.
I can't,
I,
you know,
they,
it all blends together.
It begins with an egg.
That's all I know.
So they got these fucking like preteens,
it looks like calming down,
you know,
dress like prostitutes and fucking like a be Hollywood movie.
Right.
You know,
like the ones in a pretty woman.
Yeah.
The only exciting part of that was when he was looking for a hooker and then he
runs into that fucking,
you know,
molar show in fucking champ there.
Right.
I always hated when he fucking closed shut.
She goes,
fuck it.
Laugh at all those fucking teeth.
Jesus Christ.
Uh,
I swear to God,
that clip right there is why I never dropped acid.
Cause if I ever ran into a woman like that and she did the,
I swear to God,
I don't know why,
what happened,
my fucking head would explode.
So anyways,
she's scribing and got to the start of the fucking game yet so much just fucking
bugged me.
So did doing dance routines all the shits.
So in the meantime,
the fucking warriors take the court and everybody bows him and everything and
I'm just literally going like,
oh my God.
There we go.
Stereos.
Here he goes and he starts hitting fucking threes and the second he does every
fucking jerk off and the fucking building.
Right.
Who was it making so long?
It's came running down the fucking,
I'll everybody with their cell phone cameras out taken fucking video standing up
in front of me.
Here I am paying through the nose to my seats.
I have done in the six row.
I got to stand up to watch a shoot around.
What do you film in it for the fuck are you filming?
Can't you just fucking just sit there and watch it?
I saw Larry Bird do a shoot around 1986 I still remember I got the video right?
My fucking head.
Just fucking dopes.
All these fucking Yolo do.
She's come down right with their fucking phones.
So I'm just going,
Oh God,
here we go.
You know bill pay,
you know you're the old guy now this is,
this is how the youngster do it.
This is how they fucking do it,
right?
So mercifully people finally ended up sitting down.
It's the end of the goddamn shoot around and we're ready to start the game,
right?
And I'm thinking like,
okay,
finally this fucking this,
this,
this seizure of shit of tumblers and who cheese it fucking screaming and yelling
and making noise and,
and bracelets.
Fucking Blinken is going to end and I can watch the fucking game,
right?
There's no way this horse shit goes on during the game.
There's no fucking way.
And evidently it's okay that they,
they play music through the whole fucking thing.
I'm watching Steph curry bringing the ball up and m listening to Drake,
you'll use doe call all myself,
all yogurt or yogurt photo.
Everybody clap your hands back so fucking
can barely get a sneaker squeaking.
Dude,
the NBA used to be the greatest fucking game.
If you sat down low to see the game live,
there's,
there's no,
it's not like hockey where you behind the fucking glass,
you know,
it's almost like it's soundproof and even that's still amazing to be down that
close.
But still this like this barrier.
You fucking sit right down on the court and they're right there.
The fucking ball could bounce into your lap was insane and you know,
look,
like I said,
I'll take 40% of this,
that this is just me being a grumpy old man.
Okay?
You got to keep,
the game has to keep evolving.
These kids are growing up with Dj's.
People are asking them to make noise and they like to make noise.
This is what they're fucking generation does.
Fine,
fine,
but can,
can you just dial it back a little bit?
Every time there was a time out,
all of a sudden there was all these fucking people run out it.
By the way,
the kids out there to have a kid dance team.
Can you have him do a fucking kid dance?
You know what I mean?
Jesus fucking Christ
have those fucking moves I've seen in a titty bar and I'm a fucking looking at
an eight year old dude.
Yeah.
Everybody clap your head goes to the whole fucking thing was insane.
And um,
so anyways,
in what was one of the funny things was I'm sitting there with Nia,
right?
And you know,
she's a great person.
She's not a grumpy person,
so she's just enjoying all of it.
She's taken it and she's enjoying the game,
you know?
And when all of a sudden they started like,
I swear to God in like little parachutes,
these dropdown,
um,
gift certificates to something that evidently we couldn't afford.
I don't know what it was like,
I can't even,
what the fuck it was.
Everybody's jumping up,
like leaping up trying to catch these things.
Like it's,
you know,
the end of the Vietnam War and this is a ticket to get on the last chopper out
of there.
Right.
Oh enough.
The fucking tee shirts.
All of this shit.
I hate when they sit there and they got one t shirt left and they start looking
at the section,
whatever section can make the most noise.
And just watching people like a fucking dog begging for a treat for a free
fucking clippers,
a clippers teach.
This isn't even a Lakers teacher.
This is the clippers tee.
Just watching all of those people taking all of this self esteem,
all every,
any shred of integrity and jumping up and down over a fucking eight year old to
get a free tee shirt.
I don't know.
So anyways,
so nia points out,
there's some guy sitting in the front row that she follows on a
snapchat,
I believe it's called.
I keep calling Instagram snapchat and he says,
dude,
who just goes,
Yo,
they don't want you to fucking blah,
blah blah blah,
blah blah.
And he's always doing whatever they say can't do.
And she goes,
look at him.
He's down there,
he's right there.
Oh look,
he's making a snapchat video.
She's watching the guy make the snapchat video and then she takes out her cell
phone in two seconds later.
She watches the thing and I'm watching the guy down there and and doing a
snapchat.
I just watched the guy filming.
Now I'm watching her,
her phone and by the way,
in the meantime,
Steph curry is going up and down the fire.
Everybody clap your hands,
right?
I got add.
I don't need all of that shit.
Oh,
so anyways,
as if that isn't bad enough,
as if I haven't been going on and on,
you know,
needing a,
an entire fucking box of tampons at this point.
How much I'm bitching at least like,
even though I can't hear it,
even though there's going to be somebody standing up in front of me,
even though there's shooting tee shirts at me and telling me to make some noise
and clap my fucking hands,
like I don't know where I'm at.
Okay.
Helen Keller should get like this level of fucking direction.
If she goes out,
she's dead.
Whatever.
Anyways,
Steph curry,
Steph curry goes out there immediately,
gets a foul.
I'll give it to you.
It was a foul.
All right,
three minutes later they call some ticky tack Horse Shit on the Guy.
He's got two files in the first quarter that I sit him down
and oh,
fucking Freddy stub up is sitting there going,
dude,
what the fuck?
This is the guy that paid everybody.
Yo Yo Yo yo,
after I'm fucking beside myself fucking beside myself going,
this is why.
Okay,
I fucking hate it.
This is why.
This is why these games get fixed.
This is why the NBA is fucking fixed because this is the only sport of the four
major sports that the Goddamn fucking referee can take.
The best guy out of the gate.
Just give them two quick ones in the first quarter.
Can you imagine if you went to go to a football game,
right?
Oh,
Freddy Stubhub.
Bob Going to see fucking,
I'm going to see Tom Brady versus Peyton manning the last time and go to that
fucking Broncos.
Fucking patriots play off game and whatever.
Tom Brady gets two quick ones for intentional grounding or some shit and next
thing you know he's standing on the sideline and the fucking backup quarterbacks
in there.
You're just standing there like,
dude,
are you fucking serious?
The guy spent like the whole first half of fucking bench.
It was brutal and the refs were calling fucking everything teen everybody up.
And I actually,
the only cool part about sitting down low that I saw was at one point,
is it Steve Carr said his first name,
he fuck it looks over at Doc rivers and they,
he gives doc rivers.
I like,
dude,
you fucking believe this shit.
And dark looks back.
And I'm like,
yeah,
what the fuck?
Like sharing this moment just as coaches,
like what the fuck are these refs doing?
So I don't know what happened at halftime.
If somebody called up and said,
hey man,
this is like one of the best games of the weekend,
you're fucking this up.
All right,
put your goddamn whistle away in the second half.
They let him play.
And it was,
it was,
it was beautiful.
So fucking amazing game.
Despite the fact all of that shit was going on.
Um,
I know,
I know I went on and on,
I probably went on too long.
I understand.
But like,
you know,
it's,
it's such a great game and,
uh,
you know,
I kept thinking about neo is watches all like those fucking,
uh,
you know,
reality shows and stylish shows and all that shit.
And uh,
you know,
when they trash people for what they're wearing,
if somebody comes out and they'd be like,
oh,
honey to any accessories,
you need to take a couple of things off and just go out like La,
you know,
they have like,
like too many fucking bracelets and then the fucking,
I dunno,
a hat and a scarf.
Just too many accessories that go.
You just take a couple of things off before you go out into the world,
you know,
be more Parisian,
dopey.
Tampa,
Florida.
Okay.
I Dunno why I said Tampa.
I just want to think of no class.
I just think of northern Florida.
Yeah,
I just said that you offended.
Well,
why don't you look out your fucking window past the crocodile,
over your truck with the steel balls hanging off the back of it.
Yeah.
I'm fucking with you,
Florida.
C'Mon man.
You can't be all bad if Walt Disney decided to put his world there.
Um,
that's what I feel like at those basketball games.
They just dial it back a little bit.
Okay.
Could the booty dancers be maybe,
you know,
could they at least be a junior high kids?
Could that happen?
That,
that could be nice,
you know?
Um,
could you play everybody claps their hands maybe just 18 fucking times during
the game.
You know,
if somebody pays through the fucking nose to get six to fucking row,
could I,
could I at least hear the sneakers squeaking?
They don't give a shit.
You don't give a shit what they should've done at the end of the game.
You know,
like,
you know that when you go to the joke shop and you just opened the thing up and
all the snakes would come flying out.
This where they should have done as a whole crowd.
Just give him a fucking facial fucking tee shirts and,
you know,
I gotta be honest with you,
even from me,
that was extra conti.
Um,
but once again,
dude,
I always stay to the end of the game.
I don't know why people leave.
And um,
the warriors were up.
I like fucking 1215 points or something.
I think it was no way they would see 90.
They want by 11,
they be like 15 points.
Then I think they kinda two 11 and people are leaving because there's only like
a minute and a half left.
And he was like,
well fuck this gotta beat the traffic,
which is understandable in La.
And everybody starts leaving and I'm psyched because it's getting quiet and I
can finally hear these guys out on the court.
Right.
And um,
so the clip is bring the ball up and this isn't like they've taken,
all the stars are run of the game at this point.
They just got the bench and football teams.
So what the fuck?
Even this saying,
this game,
silver clippers bring it up.
They hit a three,
right?
So now it's like a fucking eight point game warriors,
whatever they inbound the ball,
clippers stealing,
run to the three point line.
I love fucking Reggie Miller.
Boom.
Hit another three.
Now it's a five point game.
Now the people left for like,
Oh shit,
the fuck the war.
He's like,
okay,
settle down.
Shut down,
get a pass half court.
They get it.
Pass half court,
fucking clippers,
steal it again.
Go to the three point line,
boom,
hit another one.
It's a tool
point game.
The people who are left to go and fucking crazy,
this is what I wanted.
Now all of a sudden they're fucking putting,
all the a listers are coming back in to save the fucking day.
Chris Paul's back out there fucking Steph curry,
the whole fucking thing.
The warriors bring the ball back up again.
They somehow lose the ball three to the clipper guys bringing it down.
He jumps up in the air looking for somebody to pass it to and then sees like,
oh fuck,
there's not enough time yet.
And then launches and attempt that look like they brought me out on the fucking
court and it felt like way short.
It was just the wrong guy with the ball at the end of the fight.
I don't know who the fuck it was,
but uh,
even the,
it looked at me,
she just goes like,
what,
what was that as I yeah,
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
And then that was the end of the game and then they were like,
thanks for coming out man.
So,
um,
but anyways,
at the end of the day I feel like I saw Steph curry.
I got to give it up to the warriors though,
man.
Like just watching the,
watching them,
the way they move with the ball around and all of that.
And even with,
you know,
the Star on the bench,
man,
there was a Thompson,
I don't,
I don't know shit about hope as you can tell Thompson,
that guy was fucking killing them and then they got this other dude,
they'd like backup center or something.
This guy is a fucking house.
He looks like a defensive lineman if,
you know,
you put six inches on him and he had one dunk during the game.
I can't believe he didn't fucking Yank the whole rundown.
It was fucking hilarious.
He got ahead of steam and everybody just got the fuck out of the way.
Um,
and if only they weren't playing Drake during the time when it happened,
man,
I could actually could have heard that fucking earth shattering dunk was
literally 30 feet away.
I couldn't even hear it.
All right,
I'm done.
Okay.
I just had to vent.
I'm sorry guys.
I just,
you know,
just had a rough time.
All right.
Let me fucking,
I've been talking so much.
I've gone into screensaver.
I can never remember the fucking password.
Yeah.
You know what it is.
I can't talk and do this at the same time.
These stupid fucking capital letters come on one time.
One time.
Then the 52 fucking numbers that come at the end.
And of course it's wrong.
Why would it be right?
Do I literally have to hit pause?
Hang on,
hang in there with me.
Ah,
when it gets it.
All right,
let's get to,
uh,
let's get to some of the,
the advertising here for this week two,
that was literally like a 30 minute fucking bitch fest.
I literally should pay for brunch right now.
Thanks for listening guys.
I feel so much better.
All right,
blue apron.
You need to know how to cook.
Not only do you feel like you know your way around a kitchen,
but cooking at home means eating healthier and saving money instead of ordering
expensive takeout again.
But where do you sat?
Ah,
blue apron as she covered for less than $10 per meal,
blue apron delivers all the fresh ingredients you need to create home cooked
meals.
Just follow the easy step by step instructions.
Each meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
Everybody clap your hands and say,
should do have some people come up shooting fucking asparagus that you,
uh,
Maxa approachable.
No overwhelming tips to the grocery store.
No more sad takeout and haul no matter your dietary preferences.
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover and prepare dishes.
Like,
I can't read that shit.
L.
L station,
spice chicken.
You remember that?
What was that Kid's show?
T.
O.
N.
Shawn.
Shawn,
Shawn T.
Oh,
edge on [inaudible] Joe's solution.
John,
John Number.
That was at the electric company.
They were trying to teach you the how tio and says Shawn.
Sorry.
Alright,
I'll fash on spice chicken with braised red cabbage,
smashed potatoes,
abused potatoes,
domestic violence,
potatoes.
Gnocchi was shrimp,
tomato,
saffron,
and all of short rib burgers.
Can you say heart disease,
dude,
he's got disease in his fucking house,
right in your own kitchen.
Cook with,
yeah.
This is as much as spelling errors,
ingredients that you've never used before,
like watermelon,
radishes and purple potatoes.
Recipes of between 500 to 700 calories.
Proportions,
calories is spelt wrong,
delicious and good for you.
Right now you can get your first two meals for free@blueapron.com slash burr.
That's blue apron.com/bar as fucking great said.
Yeah,
everything you learn how to cook a little bit,
then that's not a lot of calories,
so you stay in shape watching you fake.
Yeah.
All right.
stamps.com everybody.
All Shit is there.
Only two reads this week.
Thank Christ.
All right,
stamps.com your to do lists can seem a little out of control.
I'm flustered so much to do,
so little time,
but there's one thing you can check off your to do list going to the post
office.
Thanks to stamps.com with stamps dot calm.
You can buy and print official US postage,
not that counterfeit shit official US postage right from your own computer and
printer stamps.com we'll send you a digital scale,
which automatically calculates the exact postage you need for any letter or any
package,
any classic male.
You'll never waste valuable time going to the post office.
Again,
you'll do it in your own house.
Do everything right now from your own desk with stamps.com print the postage you
need,
put it on your letter or package and then just hand it to your mail.
Carrie,
I love how they walk you through the whole process.
Stick it on the package using your right,
our left thumb,
or possibly your index finger.
Tuck the envelope under your arm,
walk towards your mailbox.
Don't forget to open the door before you walk through it and you're done.
I use stamps.com anytime I'm whoring myself out selling posters and that type of
shit.
You know,
anytime I want to go out there and deal with every 11 person having the
sweatiest clammy is fucking hand never and not having the decency to give me the
fist bump.
Right now,
use my last name,
birth for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer,
which includes the digital scale and up to $55 free postage.
Do not wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else.
What do I do when I get there?
Click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburthatstamps.com enter
ber.
Ah,
thank God that's over.
Thank God it's over.
I don't like it.
I don't like reading out loud.
I'll admit it.
Um,
all right,
let's continue on here with the fucking bitch fest at the is that this podcast
has become this week.
Um,
by the way,
the fucking Boston Bruins,
you know,
Adam,
boring game against the predators lost two to nothing.
And then we,
uh,
we went down three to one against the Great Dallas Stars team.
One of my favorite fucking teams to watch.
That's the team I'm rooting for out in the West,
even though I still love the Blackhawks in the kings.
And I know what you think in hockey fans.
How the fuck can you like the Blackhawks in the kinks they're rivals as cause
I'm,
I'm an eastern conference.
I don't give a shit.
I don't give a shit that you guys hate each other or I respect both of your
franchises.
All right.
Excuse me for liking what you're doing in both teams.
Um,
but I like the Dallas Stars because,
uh,
I dunno,
I just,
um,
you know,
they're the upstarts.
It's always been kings in black cock,
so you got to go for the underdog,
right.
And uh,
okay.
I don't know.
I just like watching a play.
So anyways,
why don't feel so defensive right now?
I just enjoy watching him play.
So they go up three to one and my car just sucks.
I'm going to swatch.
My team got their ass kicked,
but at least I get to watch.
Uh,
I get you,
I get to watch this Daz,
but uh,
that was it.
And I bet all you fucking cowboy fans watching the hockey.
I'm getting into this man out fighting the wall.
That's four goals in one fucking period.
It's called a period,
right?
Yeah.
I'm enjoying this man.
I'm really enjoying this.
And then that was it.
They got the old right there.
Fred right there.
Fred from fucking the pro and little cold lotion.
Few fucking cowboys Bruins went on and scored six unanswered goals.
Brad Mars,
Shannon Marchand,
however the fuck you supposed to pronounce it,
they switched it halfway through.
Um,
scored goal number 29 and 30.
I thought he had 29 goals the other day,
but he's got,
he's scored 29 and 30 sees never scored 30 goals.
Uh,
let's go,
man,
we haven't had like a big goal score in a long fucking time.
I'm opening scores 50.
Obviously it's not good.
I don't think it's gonna make it to that,
but he's king.
He could get 40.
I'm trying to think the last time.
Who was the last Bruin to score 40 goals
since I been getting the,
uh,
you know,
I'm gonna look that up right now.
My,
my only guests that I could make would be cam nearly because there was like a
five year period.
I barely watched a Bruins game because I was just,
I barely watch any sports because I was sleeping on a futon and I was rapidly
approaching my mid thirties and I had to get some shit going in my career here.
All right.
Uh,
last Bruin
to score 40 goals.
It's,
you know,
something,
it just came up before even take that out is this fucking thing listening to me
now
he thinks it's so creepy.
All right.
Who's the last born just prone to score 40 goals in a season?
I'm gonna say Cam.
Neely.
That's the last one.
I remember.
When was the last time that ruins one of the cup?
2011.
We know that who scored the most don't goes.
Why are the Bruins name the Bruins?
The named after a beer?
I'll fuck you.
They don't even know.
Sorry.
But the Audi audio that they don't even have the fucking
general McGill now the next 40 now list of players have 50 goals.
Boston Bruins.
Yeah.
It's not even here.
All right.
Some fucking NHL Nerd.
Okay.
If you could fucking answer that one for me.
Um,
Joe Thornton,
I don't fucking know.
Anyways.
Uh,
all right,
let's get on with the,
what's going on with the questions here?
Oh,
by the way,
fucking Donald Trump.
It's this guy's crushing it.
Yeah.
He just said that he,
he feels it's going to be him and Hillary Clinton.
Bernie Sanders doesn't have a chance and Hillary will make it unless she gets
indicted.
Dude,
he,
that guy is so fucking brilliant.
He just told everybody that this is what's going to happen.
And the amount of dopes after watching people dive in over each other for free
tee shirts,
they just gonna listen to them and then that's what's going to happen.
And then he fucking throws a little fucking,
uh,
you know,
a little fucking whatever pipe to the knee of Hillary go unless she gets
indicted,
which gets that shit storm going again.
Well,
Hillary Clinton get invited.
I have to tell you if those are going to be our two choices,
this is,
it has to be a low point in this country.
You know what I mean?
Well,
we have the star of a reality show on one side and then the filthy fucking
Clintons.
Oh my God.
And it's not even Bill Clinton.
You know what I mean?
It's just,
it's just fucking unbelievable.
It's like you're literally,
like I said,
[inaudible],
why would you hire the plumber's wife to come over and fix your sink?
I don't understand politics.
I don't get how you can just start at such a high fucking level with no god damn
experience.
Like how did you start as a senator,
you know?
Or that fucking the mayor in New York,
they are Bloomberg.
I got $1 billion.
Yeah,
we're gonna run this city now.
Yeah.
Get those cards out of there.
I'm going to put some chairs down.
It's like,
who the fuck is this guy?
How come you don't have to start in the mail room?
You know,
you don't have to start off as like an open micro,
like a comedian.
Well,
I was married.
You,
I pray,
I get antsy.
Shut up.
Oh God.
Listen to that fucking voice.
Listen to that voice.
Who looks at that?
Okay.
Oh,
Donald Trump had fucking wigwam be a manager.
Shave your head,
you know.
Alright,
two reads for this week.
Oh No,
I already got past this.
Let's get into the,
uh,
let's get into the questions here for this week.
Let's try to fucking calm me down.
Um,
you know what's funny is to listen to this podcast.
You wouldn't realize what a fucking great mood I'm in.
Uh,
I'm actually in a,
I'm in a great mode.
This is what I sound like when I'm in a great mood,
believe it or not.
And I still had a great time at the fucking game.
All right?
Just so you know that.
Okay.
All right.
All,
all things.
Comedy announcement.
All right,
this is not happening.
Returns to comedy central Tuesday night,
Friday,
uh,
February 23rd at 1230 after midnight.
This season.
Features long form storytelling from all things comics.
Al Madrigal.
Uh,
Christina presents ski and Steve Simone and Philippe Esparza.
So check that out on,
uh,
what'd I say?
February 23rd,
I'll,
that's tomorrow night.
Unless you're listening to this in the future and then you missed it.
Um,
this is not happening.
All right.
Now this is happening.
I'm reading a question here.
All right,
this guy,
will you know this,
this guy don't bunch of shits.
So I edited the whole thing.
Here's his question.
He says,
I'm 35 years old and still living with my father.
Pathetic.
I know.
Believe me,
it's not by choice.
I've,
I'm finally recovering from lymes disease,
which sucked away 10 years of my life and I will have my student loans paid off
in a couple of months,
months,
which also sucked away 10 years of my life,
Jesus Christ,
to
come in with the misery here in a couple of months.
My father is selling the house that we currently live in and moving into a
cheaper fixer upper so that he can be mortgage free.
I love that.
It's a great idea.
It provided you know how to fix it up.
Um,
speaking of which I got all,
all the doors in the last two interior door locks are going to work.
I got a skeleton key for all of them.
I'm so ridiculously excited and for the life of me,
I can't find anyone else who gives a shit.
I've had people over the house and I go,
look at this.
Isn't this great?
And they're like,
yeah,
why would you want to lock doors in your house?
You know,
loved it.
My mother in law,
she came over and she,
she freaked.
She was just like,
oh my gosh.
She goes,
that is so cool.
She totally got it.
Did that,
that made it worth it right there.
So anyways,
let me,
uh,
let me continue on.
Um,
he goes,
so anyways,
you know,
he paid off his student loans.
He goes,
I can send my hair is a choice I have to make.
I can either live with my dad even longer than I already have and be rent free
in this upper so that I can save up money and get my own place.
Or I can rent a shitty apartment and burn and grand a month,
which would clearly be better spent on a new house.
If I was in my twenties or early thirties I might be a little more open to the
idea of renting one,
which I did in college.
The upside of renting an apartment is having a little more confidence and
integrity when I'm out on a date,
knowing that we can retreat back to my own place,
a set of my parents' house.
We'll do why he just hit him with the Lyme disease fucking story,
you know,
and just telling me I'm living at home cause I'm not dropping a grant.
I'm going to be buying a house as long as long as you have a game plan,
women will fucking,
they'll,
they'll ride it,
they'll write it out with you for a little bit.
Feel the stainless.
Yeah.
I had Lyme disease for 10 fucking years and uh,
I finally got over it and I had to move back in with my dad and that's brutal
right there.
And moving back in with my dad.
You almost want to have that part of a whole nother set of,
you know,
run on sentence.
You just got to plow right through that and move back home.
My Dad.
But um,
I'm on,
uh,
how the fuck do you gotta see you gotta see a move back home with my dad,
but I,
I almost have enough money for a down payment on a house,
so I'm not throwing a thousand off.
Jesus Christ.
That's it out.
I'll tell you it's a riff on,
you know,
um,
and you know what?
Fuck these fucking fuck them.
Fuck them.
Just tell them what you're doing.
Yeah.
Living at home because I'm saving up to buy a house.
I am 35.
Just own it.
Yeah.
Listen,
I have my own back entrance into the house.
My Dad wants to
anyways,
just plow ahead.
If I was in my 20s or early thirties,
I might be a little more open to the idea of renting,
which I did college.
Sorry,
I already read that.
The upside of renting an apartment is having a little more Jesus Christ built.
MMM.
All right.
It's also the freedom of coming home to a quiet house and knowing that my
goddamn food will still be in the refrigerator when I get home.
My brother is also still living at home.
He suffers from migraines.
Um,
dude,
what the fuck?
Where do you,
where do you live near what's sort of fucking,
this sounds like one of those fucking movies where they,
you know that you guys eat the lead paint in your house.
Like what's going on here?
So you get Lyme disease or do you go on a fucking hike not wearing any shoes and
get bit by a tick?
I can't remember.
There's too many fucking diseases.
Anyways,
he goes,
so should I get on with my life and start pissing money away on rent or should I
stick it out a little longer and continue to live with,
with father so I can get my own fixer upper?
I love the podcast.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself in the a with a d Jay.
Kay.
Um,
all right.
I would,
uh,
look,
if you just have to stick it out a little longer,
who gives a fuck at this point?
You already did 10 years,
you know,
if,
if you can get yourself in a situation where you can actually own the place
where you're living.
MMM.
When,
I swear I should say that you're basically,
you,
instead of having a landlord,
the banks,
you landlord,
you have a mortgage and people say that you ran a d ohm.
I own,
I own a house.
We bought a house.
Oh yeah.
Outright.
No,
no,
we're making mortgage payments.
All right?
Then you don't own it.
Somebody owns you,
right?
That's what happened.
You used to be,
you'll use to use,
to be in a situation where somebody owns you month to month,
but any point you could just take off,
you could leave the plantation.
Okay.
Now you just signed up for 30 years with somebody fucking putting it in you
every fucking month.
So what I would say is I would stick it out a little bit longer with my dad and,
uh,
I would buy a house where,
you know,
it's not one of those deals where you can just make the mortgage payment.
You got to get into a situation where not only do you,
you're making the mortgage payment,
but you can throw something at the principal.
You know,
you got beat the fuck out of that and you got to beat the fuck out of it quick
because they front end load all the interests,
which to this day,
I don't know why it's legal.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
The president only makes 400 grand a year that,
oh,
I forgot.
That's right.
Yeah,
and bankers go out and have like $400,000 fucking,
you know,
like,
I wouldn't even say Christmas parties.
I mean,
that's what they probably play the outfield to come and play their daughter's
16th birthday and there's no way they pay for them for in a grant green day,
you could get green day for 400 grand,
right.
Play a half hour in your backyard.
That's a,
that's a tree.
It's 120 $533,000 each.
134 for the lead singer because he sees playing all the guitar parts and
singing.
All right.
Yeah.
I'm going to do a startup.
I Want Green Day to pay my play.
My 48th birthday.
All right.
UK,
United Kingdom.
Dear Bill,
when are you coming back to the UK and are you watching any football,
parentheses,
soccer in between Bruins games now?
I've been just,
I've been really fucking busy,
so I haven't gotten to watch any of that.
Uh,
I saw a little bit the other day.
I don't always in sub pub.
I always watch it,
man,
when I see,
you know,
if I got,
if I stumble upon it I will watch it.
But,
um,
I'm hoping to do a European tour,
towards the end of the summer.
Maybe like in August.
It'd be really interesting to go through Scandinavia,
you know,
when the sun's not going down to three and three in the afternoon,
which to be honest with you,
I actually think is pretty fucking cool.
You know?
Um,
I gotta admit when I went to Iceland and December,
that's the fucking time to go.
Don't go in the summertime when every jerk off is there.
You go in the summertime when nobody wants to go and then you go to that blue
lagoon fucking spa,
it's just,
that's naturally heated by the fucking volcanoes or whatever the fuck it is.
It's an incredible fucking incredible,
one of the,
uh,
one of the coolest places I've ever been to.
Um,
but yeah,
I'm definitely going to be coming back doing a big standup tour and I'm going to
be adding some,
uh,
eastern European countries.
Um,
and I'm really excited about that.
A buddy of mine just went to Germany,
was saying what a great time they had and he was actually in a bar and,
uh,
met somebody that knew what my stuff was or something.
He would do some of my standup jokes or something.
So I'm mostly German,
so I would be excited to,
uh,
to go back to the,
to the motherland there I'm speaking of,
which actually watched this documentary.
My wife tape was talked to that,
the charisma of Adolf Hitler on PBS.
And it was this fascinating thing how they talked about just what is charisma.
Yeah.
You know,
and they had this whole thing was saying how like Hitler could not had just no
functioning relationships with anybody one on one,
but he just crushed it in front of a crowd and how he would make them wait and
all of that shit is fucking hilarious.
Like he's waiting to start a speech.
Everyone's cheering and he's just standing there until they're dead silent.
You know,
it reminded me one time,
Nia took,
I took near to go see Erica Badu and she comes out and everyone wants you to
sing,
and she spends the first five minutes just walking around late in the incense.
So I'm watching Hitler,
Gosh,
she got this from Hitler to the fuck fucking thing.
Everybody's like,
oh,
we need to behave ourselves.
And then the performance will begin.
But they had all these creepy fucking speeches that he was getting.
He was doing this thing where he was going,
there's a group of people among us
who
can basically live anywhere.
They do business anywhere.
It doesn't matter them to them.
They live in Paris next month,
they'll live,
they'll live in fucking Vienna.
Then they'll live here and blah,
blah,
blah with no ties to their whole,
and he just keeps spoon feeding them.
You know,
he won't come out and say it,
this group of people,
because they have no attachment to Germany,
you know,
but blah,
blah,
blah blah.
Then finally somebody that crowd goes,
Joe yelled out,
Jews and Hitler never addressed it and then just kept going.
It was are you have to see this to it is the creepiest,
absolutely,
absolutely creepiest fucking thing I've ever seen in my life.
And then,
uh,
but I would,
I would be lying to you if I didn't tell you that I learned some things as far
as performance in front of a crowd.
I mean,
you got to give it up.
The guy was a beast.
I don't,
I don't even remotely agree with the guys message.
But Jesus Christ,
the guys going out in front of a crowd,
you know,
a Kevin Hart size fucking crowd,
and it doesn't say a fucking word he doesn't get to do is the exact opposite of
the clippers.
Gay makes all noise,
right?
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Hitler's got to come back and start running the NBA there.
I said it,
I said,
if he can just get past the fact that 99% of the players are African American,
I think he could do some great things for the league.
I think he quieted down.
Alright,
sorry.
Anyways,
so I will be going to eastern Europe.
That's what I was trying to say.
Or,
or Europe in general.
The UK.
There we go.
All right.
Apple fives.
The FBI,
Dia,
big brother Billy,
what are your thoughts on the battle between apple and the FBI regarding hacking
into the,
the phones of the San Bernardino terrorist?
Also,
just the fact that the FBI has the phones for two months and can't get into
them,
put a dent into any government overreach conspiracy theories.
Uh,
no.
And he says the situation with the apple is FBI wants to apple to create an
operating system that would allow for them to hack encryption on the phone.
Uh,
they would upload the system to the terrorist's phone to allow them to unlock
it.
However,
what they would upload this system to the terrorist's phone to allow them to
unlock it.
However,
if apple does this,
the operating system be used by the FBI and others to totally compromise any
security on any iPhone in the future,
uh,
the solution is simple.
It's just like,
just bring the phones to us and we'll hack into it.
And whatever information need on the phones will do that for you.
Yeah.
Once again,
because of these terrorists con,
what you're gonna do is you're gonna allow all the,
you know,
these fucking lunatics at the top to take even more power and privacy away from
you.
And I can just
simplest way to tell you this is just like,
you know,
the,
the amount of people out there that can actually handle power,
uh,
is,
it's very rare.
I mean,
look in my business,
okay?
You see what happens?
You know,
everybody's down to earth,
everybody's cool,
and all of a sudden you get your own Sitcom and next thing you know,
you're banning people from the set your tip and shit over.
And nobody's saying shit because you make it all this fucking money.
You don't handle it well,
right?
Being like
being like in the top levels of government and security,
it's the same fucking thing.
I don't think they handle it well.
I think it's way too much freedom and I'm sick of people saying shit like,
well,
hey man,
if you're not doing anything then what are you worried about?
I'm worried about the fact that,
you know,
just,
well,
human being stupid,
we're awful.
We're fucking terrible.
People were terrible with the amount of access that we have now.
You don't need to give people more access and I don't feel like,
you know,
they keep just hiding behind this whole fucking thing of like,
you know what?
We're just going to use it for the bad people.
It's like,
yeah,
but you get to decide who the fuck's bed.
That Snowden guy,
he had to walk away what they were building.
It was like the fucking Batman movie.
They spire on their own fucking people.
They're lunatics.
I don't know what they do.
I always picture him just sitting there fucking,
I don't know.
Do do you know,
like that Snowden Guy,
he says when he stays in a fucking hotel room,
he unplugs the phone because they had that speaker phone.
Do you know that down at the front desk they can turn it on and just listen to
whatever you're doing in there.
If you know,
fucking Yelei talking to yourself,
rubbing one out,
whatever the fuck you doing in the privacy,
your own fucking hotel.
And they can just listen in on that shit.
It's fucking,
it's just the whole thing is creepy and um,
yeah,
no,
it's,
I can't imagine,
you know what,
by the time,
you know,
if I live,
to be like 9,100 years old,
like I would like to,
um,
I want to see the fucking,
I want to live in every fucking decade.
You,
I want to get to the 60s again.
I was born in 1968.
I want to make it,
you know,
I just keep thinking shit like that.
I want to make it right.
So,
um,
I can't imagine like the lack of privacy that there'll be if you live that long
just with like people with like drones and shit like that,
like the cameras and just how like I think in the future,
right,
they're going to do that and have like these,
uh,
like microchips link Mres,
you know,
and like somebody walks by and somebody just hit you with a little mist in all
these little microchips.
Go on.
Yeah.
And when you shower,
like most of them come off,
but like a few still stick on you and then your next door neighbor can just
watch your whole fucking life.
There'll be no more TV shows.
We'll just be spying on each other.
I don't know.
I think it's all fucking creepy and I think that's way too much.
I don't think the FBI needs to fucking do that.
I think apple should work with the FBI and uh,
if there's ever like somebody that they want to fucking check in on,
you know,
let them do it.
Sam Columbine.
Um,
hang on one second.
Yeah.
Hey,
I'm finishing up my podcast.
Let me call you back in five minutes.
All right?
Yup.
Cool.
Um,
all right.
Let's get onto the next one.
All right.
Gay Friend.
Hey Bill.
First off,
thanks for the lungs.
Well,
you're welcome.
I'm 30 years old and decided to go back to school two years ago to study
chemistry.
I'm an idiot like you,
but with enough effort,
anything is possible.
Yeah.
I believe Kevin Garnett said that.
Thank
[inaudible].
Um,
during my first semester back,
I befriended a gay guy.
I am not gay myself,
nor am I homophobic.
I've also never had a gay friend.
We have a lot in common except for the fact that he likes to give and take it up
the ass.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you can set except that he likes gay section.
All right.
I don't proofread these.
I just stumbled on the sentences.
Here we go.
During that first semester,
I started to get the feeling that he liked me.
Uh,
I started to get uncomfortable studying with him and stopped answering his phone
calls for a few days.
After those two days,
I decided to call them,
explain my concerns.
I told him that I've never had a gay friend before.
I think he's a cool guy,
but I also explained that I'm getting the feeling that he thinks he might have a
chance to.
That's you handled it perfectly.
He goes,
he laughed and he assured me that he wasn't hitting on me and knew I wasn't gay.
He also told me that if he feel he cry,
if he,
if I feel he crosses a line to tell him,
tell him.
Okay,
great.
I said,
I don't know dude.
He said he wasn't hitting on you and then he's kind of like,
yeah,
but if I cross the line
I,
the way I look at the end of the day,
it's a guy.
All right.
And guys think,
you know,
if you're talking to them,
you want to hook up,
right.
That's why women,
you know when they walk down the street,
guys who like smiles say hello.
It's like I can't,
or else you think I want to fuck you.
And then I gotta deal with that level of interaction.
That's why I got to walk down the street with this Donald Trump.
Look on my face.
Right.
The same thing.
I always feel,
I feel that with like gay guy,
she can't be,
can't.
We can only be so fucking nice or are they going to think they got a shot
because they were born with a deck.
That's what I taught.
I did a bit about that.
Your Dick's a dreamer.
You're dick believes,
man.
It's fucking wave and everybody around the third base.
All right.
Now I'm in my second year of school,
fourth semester and we have more of the same classes but not together over the
winter break.
He called me and asked if I wanted to go to the bar with him and some other
friends from school.
I happily said yes and drove to the bar.
After about two hours,
he asked me if I have any weed and if I'd smoke,
smoke him down.
Are we still talking about weed here?
What are we doing here?
I said,
sure,
let's go to my truck and smoke a bowl.
During this drunken stoners session,
he proceeds to get well.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Can you gotta hear that?
So yeah.
Listen,
dude,
you know what you got was right.
You called them on the shit and he said that he wasn't,
and I knew it with that fucking line,
but if I ever crossed the line,
let me know.
Dude.
He was trying to wear you down.
He was trying to hang in there long enough that you finally just said,
you know what?
Fuck it up.
Okay,
so basically,
okay.
He proceeds to get worried.
He goes,
basically tell you that he knows I'm not gay,
but I'm the kind of guy he likes and I'm one of his best friends and I was,
life sucks because he's gay.
I just started laughing and saying,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
I'm too nice of a guy to say,
get the fuck away from me.
So I let him finish his thoughts.
He was drunk and being emotional too,
which was annoying.
He reminded me of my ex girlfriend.
I'm just glad he didn't start crying.
Anyway,
after way after he was done,
I said,
that's great,
but I'm not wired that way.
Sorry.
He kept going on and on asking me if I'm sure there isn't any secret hidden,
desired buried deep within me.
Oh yeah,
dude,
it's late night.
It's late at night.
This guy,
he's going all in.
Uh,
I explained to him that if I was doing the same thing to a girl that I had a
crush on,
I would be considered a creep and that the girl wouldn't want to hang out with
big anymore.
Dude,
why are you writing me,
man?
You've got all the,
you're handling all of this perfectly.
Um,
I already failed because the second he got weird and my truck,
I would be like,
yeah,
yeah.
Um,
this was about two months ago and I've ignored him since.
He called me three times and I ignored them.
Two of the calls were in the middle of the night.
Oh,
Jesus.
One 30 to 2:30 AM,
which leads me to believe he was being drunk and emotional.
Exactly.
He goes,
just like a 23 year old girl.
I don't see him at school anymore because I avoid him on purpose.
My question to you is,
am I doing the right thing?
Yes,
you're totally doing the right thing.
It's just cause you get both guys and that because he's gay and he's all like
basically in the media,
they're always considered victims.
If there's any sort of solid,
like you gotta be more accepting.
You know,
at some point if somebody is making you fucking uncomfortable and you fucking
address and they still cross the line,
if that's something you're not comfortable with it.
Yeah,
fuck off.
It's over.
Beat it.
You fucking creeping me out,
you know?
Anyways,
he goes,
my question to you is,
am I doing the right thing?
I've never gone out of my way to avoid someone like this except for a girl.
After I break up with them,
I have no desire to hang out with them anymore.
It's not that big of a deal.
It's not like a work friend you hang out with,
but then one of you gets a different job and the two of you stop hanging out.
I do feel bad though because he has had a hard life.
He's the classic Gay Guy.
I grew up in Texas and was harassed and is hated by his dad.
It sucks,
but it's not my problem.
I used to listen to his problems and try to give them advice on life and
happiness and be a good friend.
But after that whole truck and his incident,
I don't want to do that anymore.
Thanks for the help.
Hope you and the lovely Nia.
Have a great day.
Yeah,
no dude,
you're fucking,
you handled it perfectly.
You never a jerk to the guy.
You told them exactly how you were feeling at the end of the day.
You had respect for yourself in your own boundaries,
which he didn't.
So fuck off,
you know?
Yeah.
Teach.
You May,
uh,
you know,
teach them a lesson next time he has a straight friend,
just be,
be a friend.
They'll get high.
Go into his truck and try to fuck them.
Yeah.
It's pretty straight forward.
Alright.
Germaphobe bill though.
I can't,
I don't know.
Lucas site.
What the fuck does that word?
I gotta look that word up.
He said some fucking spaceship.
Is that a,
uh,
I don't know what that means.
I feel like half the podcast is laughing at me and the other half is pretending,
pretending like they know what the fuck it means.
Leukocytes,
a colorless cells
that circulates in the blood and bodily fluids and is involved in counteracting
foreign substances and diseases and so I'm a white self.
That stat,
you never realize how fucking original that is.
I hope I said the word right.
Jesus Christ.
That was fucking brilliant.
My Hat's off to you and also ties in with Germaphobe.
You know,
whenever you get sick,
your white cell count goes up.
Do you realize how many fucking levels that installed is working?
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Tip of the hat to you.
All right.
A few days ago I was stretching in the gym with the girl I was dating.
She picked up her phone from a bench,
looked at the screen and said,
God,
my screen is so dirty.
And then proceeded to use her tongue to lick the phone screen and wipe it off
with their sleeve.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Jay,
just when you thought getting high with your gay friend and he goes for your
Dick in your truck was the fucking weirdest,
almost uncomfortable thing you were going to Jesus.
Yeah.
He goes,
I dry heaved and she got mad at me claiming that she was a medical student and
done things like that.
Doing things like that was good for,
for my immune system.
Yeah.
Fucking Med students always got to tell you they are med students.
He goes,
I couldn't get over it.
I had to get away from her.
Now it's in my psyche that maybe I am a German folk.
When I use an ATM or Debit Card,
Pin pad,
I always have to wash my hand touching those things.
Grosses me out.
Am I a Germaphobe p.
S how many hands do you shake a day?
Um,
no dude,
you're girlfriend is a med student,
but she's also gross.
That's fucking disgusting.
This fucking disgusting period.
Okay.
There's so many other ways where you can just go into the fucking gym is enough
to keep your immune system up.
You don't need to lick your phone.
You fucking pig.
Disgusting.
That's fucking gross.
All right.
End of story.
No,
you're not a Germaphobia and intelligent human being.
That's an,
you know,
you just aware.
Yeah.
I don't like touching those fucking things when I go to the airport.
I got to let you,
I've got to get on that little shuttle busting and they're like,
hold on.
Before the fucking thing starts.
I always pulled down the sleeve of my jacket and I hold onto it like dead.
Yeah.
I don't need fecal matter in mucus and Tj's and God knows what else is fucking
on that day.
All right,
gross.
You're not a Germaphobe.
Alright.
How many hands do I shake a day?
Uh,
I don't know.
Sometimes zero.
Sometimes a if I do wish.
I don't,
I don't fucking know.
I know,
but I,
I go and I wash my hands afterwards and I don't touch my face after I do it
because I'm afraid I'm going to get pink guy.
But,
uh,
I don't shake a lot of hands.
MMM.
But I will say people love coming out of the bathroom and they'd be like,
hey,
Belle.
And then shaking your hands.
I,
I really got an in the moment,
get better and be like,
dude,
not you just came on your mind.
Give me the elbow,
dude.
You just came out of the bathroom.
I don't know you.
I don't know if you're good at washing your hands.
I want to know you like that.
Alright.
Dilemma.
Hey Bill.
Oh,
that reminds me a long time ago.
I worked at the Improv in Dallas and I pissed off this fucking old,
I think I pissed off this older texts and guy,
or maybe this was this weird idea of humor.
He came up and shook my hand right at the end of the show.
I say,
hey man,
thanks for coming out.
And he just goes,
I just paid.
Yeah.
That was like,
all right,
well,
you know,
I'm not gonna do anything with my hand.
My hand is,
you could have your urine on it.
It's fine.
I'm not going to eat.
I'm just going to shake a bunch of other hands now and they're going to have
your pee on it and then I'm going to wash my hands and it's going to be over.
You know what?
I mean,
you don't think you got,
you just went into the bathroom.
You don't have any idea what's on your fucking heads.
Um,
that's now on my heads.
Yeah,
we're all filthy.
Alright.
Dilemma.
Hey Bill.
Uh,
so I'm in a bit of a tight situation.
Me and buddies were playing to take on taking a weekend trip down to Austin to
attend a music festival.
My leg grandma is getting married the same week,
the same weekend as the concert.
Obviously I have to pick
bye ladies.
Grandma's getting married the same weekend as the concert.
Obviously I have to pick which event I'm going to attend.
Your girlfriend's grandma's getting married.
Well,
when the fuck did grandma have her mother when she was like 12?
My girl,
there's no choice here.
This isn't a dilemma.
This is like an obvious,
he goes,
my girl left it completely up to me with no hard feelings attached,
at least from her.
I'm afraid of upsetting her family by not going to the wedding.
Fuck that.
Go to the fucking wedding.
Look,
if you're going to marry this girl,
you have to establish early that you're not going to every stupid fucking
function you have to do that.
He goes,
but I should mention that my,
uh,
my girls,
grandma doesn't really care much for me or so it seems she tells my girlfriend
that she should explore her options a bit while she's still young also.
And I also have not been formally slashed,
officially invited.
My girlfriend and I have been dating for two years,
so it's not like I'm a new boyfriend or anything.
What should I do?
I'd love to hear the lovely Nias take as well.
If she's around,
unfortunately she's not around.
Um,
dude,
fuck that.
You go down with your friends and you go to the concert.
You have a great fucking time.
Okay.
And if this woman doesn't like you,
at the end of the day,
she's going to die soon.
So who gives a fuck?
Okay.
It gives a shit,
Sally.
Her mom doesn't like it,
then that's a problem because she's going to be around and you're going to have
kids and she's going to fucking show up and it's going to be a big fucking pain
in the ass.
Grandma gives a fuck.
Right.
Should explore her options.
Is she still running around single and her fucking eighties you know,
she's just projecting our own regret of that fucking
oxen driver.
She married back in the 1920s whatever the fuck she did.
Yeah,
go to the concert.
It's not a dilemma to go to the concert.
Just tell your girlfriend so you know what I just said,
I'm going to go to the concert.
I have a good time at the wedding and just fucking leave it at that and if she
gives you a rough time about it,
don't bring up the fact that your grant or grandma doesn't like you and blah,
blah blah,
because then she's going to try and fix it.
Now.
You guys need to spend more time together.
Just tell her.
I would just,
I would rather go to the concert.
Yeah.
Yes.
And just leave it at that.
If she gives you a ton of shit,
just be like,
listen,
you know,
if I invited you to somebody,
you,
you also had plans to go to a concert and he chose to do that.
I,
I wouldn't give you a rough time about it.
I would want you to do what was going to make you happy.
I would appreciate if you extend me the same courtesy.
Yeah,
I see it now.
I was going to say you fucking self so and so don't,
don't,
don't do the last part.
All right,
so that's what I would do.
All right.
Okay.
There you go.
All right.
That's a podcast for this week.
Everybody beat by de facto heads.
Um,
thank you for listening.
it's,
they get everybody that's uh,
you know,
coming out to the shows this weekend at Foxwoods,
I have some people were talking about,
you know,
the ticket prices and everything.
I can't control that people go on and buy some of these fucking yeah.
Scalping ticket things.
You know,
the stub hub peoples are the fucking world,
so I got to figure something out with that.
I Know Louis C K does something where he sells tickets,
you know,
on his own website.
But my thing is like,
well then how do you stop them from just going to your website and buying up a
bunch of tickets and incenting the fucking price through the roof?
Like how do you do that?
Cause I don't want you guys getting fucked over,
um,
by,
I can't tell you this.
If you do go and you do pay through the nose,
there won't be anybody screaming and yelling and shooting fucking tee shirts at
you while I'm doing my Dick and shit jokes.
All right?
Okay,
that's a podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on Thursday.